[Música]
en France 24 lo tenemos más información
internacional Pero ahora con una mirada
económica de la mano de nuestro
periodista especializado en el tema Juan
Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo buenas noches
Nos acercamos al final de la semana Así
es María Clara estamos aquí para hablar
de economía y en esta economía siguen
las disputas de compañías y demás como
ya lo hemos visto entre meta y también
la compañía de Twitter pero ahora son
dos compañías de mensajería que están
demandando a la ciudad de Nueva York Por
qué Así es pues la demanda está
encabezada por dos de ellas
específicamente es Uber y doordash Pero
hay otras empresas de entrega de
alimentos que también presentaron
demandas este mismo jueves la razón
buscan eliminar una novedosa ley que
busca establecer una tarifa base para
aquellos que trabajan pues para este
tipo de aplicaciones Los partidarios de
esta ley que es la primera de este tipo
en Estados Unidos la defienden porque
dicen que los empleados en la gran
manzana ganan alrededor de 11 dólares
por hora después de gastos esto en estas
aplicaciones y pues dicen que es muy por
debajo del salario mínimo de la ciudad
que son 15 dólares y es que por lo
general los trabajadores de estas
plataformas son tratados como
contratistas independientes y no como
empleados de la empresa por lo que las
leyes generales de salario mínimo no se
aplican o no no se aplican a ellos pero
si se aplica esta ley la plataformas de
entrega necesitarían alimentar
o aumentar el número de viajes
completado por hora para contener los
números de los nuevos gastos de mano de
obra y también tendrían que reducir las
áreas de servicio lo que al final
afectaría a los consumidores y
restaurantes Este es un escenario que
han planteado planteado pues las
empresas y es lo que dicen ellos Bueno
usted bien lo señala que las
contrataciones o el tipo de contrato que
tendrían y las desventajas laborales son
la razón por la que están demandando
pero en esta demanda Cuáles son algunos
de los argumentos legales leamos lo que
dicen las dos principales empresas a
continuación empezamos con Uber que dice
si se permite que esta ley
causará un daño inmediato e irreparable
a Uber en forma de pérdida de buena
voluntad con los mensajeros y los
clientes y en forma de costes no
recuperables en el caso de doordash dice
este proceso de reglamentación
fatalmente defectuoso y subjetivo
empeoró las políticas ya problemáticas
eso es lo que dicen ellos sigamos en
Estados Unidos porque este país se
reunió con México y Canadá Qué pasó en
el primer día hablamos de la reunión del
tratado entre México Estados Unidos y
Canadá más conocido como El temec este
año la reunión se enfoca en evaluar los
avances de este tratado y la integración
de las cadenas de valor en ese sector
Pues en futuros como semiconductores
baterías de litio autos eléctricos
equipo médico de alta tecnología entre
otros pero Pese a que Existen algunas
diferencias de larga Data por las
restricciones de acuerdos comerciales
con energía y el maíz específicamente
con México las tres funcionarias que
iniciaron las reuniones este dijeron
desde México que buscaban aumentar el
crecimiento económico y la inversión
para pues tratar de Elevar también la
competitividad de América del Norte y
Mientras tanto
en China en una atención comercial y que
es la segunda alta funcionaria en viajar
en los últimos meses después de Anthony
Así es María Clara la secretaria del
tesoro de Estados Unidos inició hoy
reuniones que se extenderán hasta el
domingo con varios funcionarios chinos
aunque no con el presidente
que se dan cuando esta misma semana
Beijing intensificó una batalla
tecnológica al imponer restricciones a
la exportación del germanio y el galo
que estuvimos hablando aquí el galio dos
minerales clave para la fabricación de
Microchips y vehículos eléctricos y
cuáles son las implicaciones de esa
prohibición pues revisémoslo María Clara
pues lo primero que hizo fue Elevar los
precios de estos metales a medida que
los fabricantes se apresuraron a
asegurar su suministro pero también hizo
aumentar los temores de que esas
restricciones posiblemente se puedan
extender otros minerales como las
tierras raras cuya producción está bajo
El dominio de China que supera de lejos
a Estados Unidos que es el segundo
productor las tiras raras son un grupo
de 17 elementos que se utilizan en
productos que van desde láseres y
equipos militares hasta imanes para
vehículos eléctricos Y turbinas eólicas
así también como para productos
electrónicos de consumo como celulares
como los iPhone y demás y como ya hemos
visto todos los temas están conectados
esto ha tenido alguna implicación en los
indicadores de este jueves evidentemente
y vamos a empezar por nuestra región
porque las bolsas ahí cerraron en su
mayoría en rojo México perdió un 1,17% y
Brasil
1,78% ahora vamos a otro indicador Y es
de redes sociales porque pese al Boom de
su nueva aplicación hoy meta cerró con
una pérdida del
0,75% ya revisaremos qué sucederá más
adelante Usted menciona meta que ya
habíamos dicho la pelea que tiene con
Twitter por su aplicación streets qué
cifras tenemos al respecto pues vamos a
revisarlas hoy traemos varias de ellas y
lo haremos con el siguiente gráfico
porque la primera es que pues el
lanzamiento fue en más de 100 países y
aquí hay un punto importante y es que
están por fuera los 27 países de la
Unión Europea que todavía se está
mirando Qué sucede ahí con el tema de La
regulación Pues de datos los 500
caracteres por publicación un dato
también importante porque en Twitter
solamente se pueden dos ochenta esto es
casi el doble son 220 más caracteres que
una persona puede publicar aquí hablamos
también de los 10 millones de descargas
y aquí Mark Zuckerberg decía yo me
acosté cuando me acosté a dormir habían
10 millones de descargas y cuando me
levanté el jueves ya habían 30 millones
de descargas esto antes del mediodía y
cerramos con otro dato y son los 100
millones de usuarios en dos meses Esta
es una previsión que hace una de las de
las de las casas de análisis diciendo
que en dos meses esta aplicación podría
superar este número y es algo que
solamente ha logrado charge y si lo
logra pues estaría superando y sería una
de las aplicaciones más descargadas en
en la historia increíble Juan Pablo
Gracias por las noticias económicas
y nosotros seguimos en el debate